Hey, Vsauce.
Michael here.
And this video is to tell you that I released
a brand new Vsauce leanback - a playlist of
some of my favourite videos from all over
YouTube, with me hosting in between.
You can only really watch it on a computer,
so if you're on a mobile device or something
else weird wait until you're in a better position
to lean back.
To make it worth your while, in this video
I've got news, a fact and math.
Three things.
First of all, the news item.
Hazel.
Vsauce t-shirts.
Let's try to act a little bit more mature.
We've got the logo,
we've got brains and here's the fact.
Are you ready?
For this one drop some knowledge and hear
some order happen.
You're not using this take, are you?
Baby... Baby carrots are made out of adult carrots.
No!
Weird adult carrots, they shave them into
the little baby carrots that we know.
But they just, it just stops growing and it's
a baby carrot.
No.
They take adults, especially ugly adult carrots
that look weird and they shave them into good shapes.
I don't know, dog food or something.
But wait a second.
Baby corn really is baby corn.
It's normal corn and they don't let it grow
to adulthood, they kill it when it's a kid
and then they serve it to you and you eat
it when it's still a baby.
That makes me feel better.
Now it's time for some mathematics.
Okay, first of all, it does not matter at
all what order the cards are in.
This is completely a mathematical trick.
So anyone can do it and there's no slide of
hand involved.
I'll shuffle it, so I can just prove that
to you.
All we need are 9 cards.
One, two, three.
One, two, three?
Three, very good.
Now, pick a pile that you fancy.
Alright, now choose a card out of that pile.
You can look at them all, yeah.
Okay.
Okay, now you can totally show me what it
is, 'cause it's a math trick.
So put it right on top.
Three of diamonds, good choice.
Now, what I'm gonna do is take the rest of
our 9 cards and stick them right on top.
The rest of the deck, all this whole mess
thing here, doesn't matter.
Get it out of the way.
Now, because of the range of numbers of letters
in every single card's name and because your
card is the third from the bottom, three of
diamonds, this will always work.
Let's spell out your card's name.
Three of diamonds.
T. H. R. E. E.
Rest on top.
What's the next word?
Of.
O. F.
Rest on top.
Diamonds.
Spell it out for me.
D. I. A. M. O. N. D. S.
Rest on top.
Okay.
Now.
Okay, are you ready for this?
Yes.
Alright, now what I want you to do is say
the phrase "Hazel is really super awesome."
Okay.
Okay?
Uhm.
As I drop a card you say a word.
Okay.
Hazel is really super awesome.
There's your card.
No way!
That'll work every single time.
Try it at home.
I learned it from mismag, a magician I've
included in the leanback before.
I put an interactive trick of his in this
leanback, it's a long one, you're gonna learn
a lot of different stuff that goes all over
the place, it's gonna pack your brain with
knowledge.
Alright?
It's gonna all covered in Vsauce when we're done.
So start than leanback.
And as always,
thanks for watching.
Bye.